a conspiracy website can you believe
that there are conspiracy websites on
the internet I can't believe it
they are saying that they have
definitive proof that aliens exist and
they were at area 51 let's take a look
at the video right here this is the
proof people yes there's no audio there
is it there's some sort of body on that
thing it looks like some look there's a
man running
look there's something cameraman wait
here we're gonna maybe get look at
something we have proof mannequin all
right so this is all from the Australian
magazine uncensored they claimed that
the footage is authentic and they say
they've had their experts examine it
whenever you get experts from a
conspiracy website right those are
really
they've got proof yeah I sense that you
guys don't buy that this is is that
proof enough I mean it did look like
something right clearly that was an
extraterrestrial and if I wanna you know
hardcore news I go to that Australian 51
was that well area 51 a magazine is
uncensored there you go there uncensored
because they want you to know the truth
yeah pretty sure that's a clip from a
movie that is an alien autopsy like
that's from that movie they might be
from there there's like some alien
showing yeah that's an interesting
website they had a poll on there and it
was like does this you know is this
proof and 26 percent of people said no
and then the rest said yes yeah as part
of it that the they'll never be able to
prove it at least from the old video
because it looks old yeah so you know to
me mate let's just go with it for a
second okay and be like alright that was
legit whatever we saw that but it looks
old so like there's no real like until
they showed me a body in front of me why
would you believe anything and why are
they bringing it up now after all these
years they're inside guy that unearthed
the tape that the government doesn't
want you to see I think it was like in
the first Charlie Chaplin alien I bought
it until I scrolled down to the bottom
of this website yeah and they had a link
they were like do you want to see more
about aliens and I click to see what
links they had and there was one that
said our aliens preparing to go to war
handguns spotted on Mars
oh now I see that's why you're good to
do that extra research like well because
you're evidence-based I mean what would
it take for you guys to believe it I
mean even if the government even you
know parade it out what they claimed was
a Martian and it was a body like would
would that be enough for you because I
don't believe the government when it
comes to most things yeah I mean I
personally believe that there's life
outside the earth you know I feel like
that's what inspired this jacket but you
know just a video I mean anyone can make
a video and special effects are so
common these days I mean an
eight-year-old kid can whip up something
on iMovie so it looks like that's what
happened - yeah yeah he was it was in
intro class I think yeah
so what would it what would it take for
you to actually believe testable
repeatable evidence peer-reviewed
scientific research but I mean like I
agree with you of like I also think that
it would be you know not that far off to
believe that there's something out there
I mean the universe is very big and we
are very small so to think that we're
the only intelligent life out there
doesn't really seem likely to me either
but yeah a video like that is not gonna
be like oh wow there's aliens and we
have bodies of them right so I'm totally
on board that too
we're just by you know our son is just a
very average star actually and there's
gajillion how many stars are there good
Julian there's a gajillion stars out
there and the earth is just a rock that
happens to be floating in this proximity
with the right amount of warmth and
water and bus so there's gotta be some
other life out there but what do you
think about the people that absolutely
don't believe it that absolutely believe
that everything is right here does that
seem myopic to you or is there myopic
yeah I mean I think we are
they're all so egotistical if they think
that we are it and this is the only
thing that matters I mean there's been
existence billions of years before us
and I mean I'm definitely not a science
expert yeah but I how could you how
could there not be yeah I think about it
people think it's all here I think that
people who claim to know something a
hundred percent when they have no way of
knowing something a hundred percent I
just
that's you know a little bit ignorant
yeah host minded so alright do you know
for a hundred percent that aliens are
here are you an alien have you been
visited by aliens comment in the section
right down below and don't forget to
subscribe like and all that other good
stuff